[Music]
all right so let's shift to Jordan
Peterson a little bit because you are a
student at the University of Toronto
that's where he's been teaching for many
years this whole kerfuffle over
transgender pronoun is faulty stolen so
like everyone's yelling at each other
and hates each other I blame him what's
the atmosphere like at the school
actually he's not teaching there right
now we can now be on tour in the book
and the whole thing but has the
atmosphere change then do you think it's
directly related to some of the stuff
that he unearthed I think it has changed
because there you can see the groups you
get and when someone you know has a
slightly right-wing or it's funny
because the fact that they associate
individualism and the fact that they
associate thinking for yourself with
being right-wing it's like why would you
want to do that it should not be anyways
why wouldn't you want to be a right-wing
like what yeah so the when you're a
little bit more right-wing I guess they
tend to say that you know you are
joining Peterson fan and you hate
transgenders and blah blah blah like
there's a clear divide you can tell
which side people are on but yeah I
think it was bound to happen regardless
and just again because of the Trump
presidency
can we just blame Trump for everything
yes you're in America too so that's how
it yeah yeah watch out so you sort of
view it as kind of a necessary evil that
he sort of got this stuff I mean again
it goes to what we were talking about
earlier you're like some of these people
get these issues out there and then
hopefully some goodness after them yeah
definitely and I think the other thing
is from allowed people like I said
earlier to think for themselves in the
sense to understand that maybe not
everything is how it seems maybe things
that I'm learning is not exactly how it
is and you know I you know I may
disagree with his politics like because
I'm a liberal in general but I do think
that yeah it was bound to happen and
Trump kind of shook things up and a lot
a lot more people are engaging in
politics now which is so exciting and
also really scary at the same time what
is it that it I mean
see it right there I think just this
morning I tweeted sunny out to that
effect it's like wow it's incredibly
exciting doesn't mean things are gonna
be good I actually I believe things
actually are gonna get better because
there's so many cool new young people
like yourself out there putting out
ideas like I have hope but yeah it
doesn't mean that's how it's gonna go
yeah it might go the other way yeah but
then the other thing is that because the
far-left are scared that people are
starting to you know do more research
we're starting to Google things nowadays
we've started to it that's why they want
to control Google exactly so now you
can't find any right information you can
only find theirs yeah yeah but now
they're changing definitions of things
so I mean the definition of racism is no
longer individual it has to do with
power plus privilege so in other words
only white people can be racist towards
minorities minorities cannot be racist
towards white people they've also taken
hold of the like Student Union's and
Jordan Peterson has talked about this a
lot so sorry what was the question
generally was about Jordan and being a
student at University of tried religious
yeah yeah I feel like the student unions
are just influencing a lot of the
students and influencing a lot of the
events that are happening they claim to
speak on behalf of all students so and
they claim that they're fighting against
racism except they define it a different
way I mean who's gonna go against
someone that says they're fighting
against racism and sexism and every
other buzzword that they can throw out
there you have to accept it and because
they've changed the definition of racism
they started to have events and there's
a white privilege conference which I
actually did a video on yeah it's the
University yeah so that's the way that
they're countering it they're countering
the facts with just you know all that
alternative facts with their own BS
feminist studies ideas I don't even know
but that's I guess the way they're doing
it they're trying to influence students
from schools so then when they get out
they can become more liberal so the
things that Jordan talks about when he
talks about the individual and when he
talks about why the government shouldn't
be able to talk tell you what pronouns
to use etc etc you see these things it's
all directly related to everything else
that you've been talking about here ya
know for sure and I think it's also
about sorry I just blanked Oh
we were at a Jordan event that's that's
where we met about a month ago in
Toronto and was it a white supremacist
oh yeah in Selma I was stoned on my way
out I mean but were you surprised at all
when you saw what an interesting diverse
young I think most of them I've been
telling people it's about 60/40 yeah
male-to-female but sometimes it's even
closer to 5050 yeah no I think it's
pretty diverse and I've gone to several
events like political events I guess
where I look in the crowd I'm like wow
there's a lot of minorities here there's
women here there's been here there's
everyone here and sorry where I blanked
was the idea that you can't you can't
debate something that's where that was
the whole Peter I'm like ranting here so
gets me like all excited because I was
there but the fact that you can't debate
certain topics the fact that you can
debate whether or not we should use
certain pronouns because they say well
you're questioning my identity you're
questioning me as a person my humanity
they turn it around and make it sound
like you hate that person and that's the
thing is it's not like I agree with
Peterson or I agree with the you know
the students I just want to hear both
sides that's all I'm asking for
something we can all make an informed
you know conclusion but they don't want
you to hear both sides they want you to
hear their side and that is the only
side you see what happened with like
Lindsey Shepard as well where she you
know played at Peterson debate where
there are all sides and they don't want
you to hear that they only want you to
hear their side and that's where that's
one thing I hate the most is the lack of
discussion yeah so I'm glad you brought
up Lindsey because that also is
happening at Canada that was that
Wilfred Laurier University now there's a
lawsuit that she's involved and I
suspect I read some of the initial brief
I mean I think this thing's gonna be a
bloodbath the University but what does
that say is happening in Canada in a
larger way I think you've kind of hit on
this a little bit like you guys are
almost having like this like Trump
hangover or something where or even the
black lives matter thing like it didn't
start in America as you said race
relations were different in Canada I
would argue they're still great here for
sure
Canadians are just nicer okay
you know we've done two shows in Toronto
and the shows were totally nice and
present but like we've gone to some
other cities where and I find it's
usually in the progressive cities so
it's been in you know San Francisco and
it's been in Seattle and a couple of the
others where the crowds are the craziest
yeah most raucous which is what I like
most because they kind of they need his
message yeah Toronto you guys are very
pleasant I think we're gonna we're
getting to a point where we need his
message I think it's it's getting a
little scary especially with Trudeau as
our prime minister he's kind of kowtow
to a lot of the social justice warrior
and the fact that he's even you know
talking to black lives matter Toronto
who you know the leader one of the
leaders said she wants to kill white men
she tweeted that she wished she can kill
all white men and the other one actually
stole 300 thousand dollars from my
student union stole it and said the she
on her last day she filed her over time
and she's filed thousands of hours of
overtime I said she's about 300 yes it's
a third of our entire budget of our
student unions but a third and here's
the best part of it she files that
obviously there's alerts that go off you
can't take that much money for what are
your student union president three
hundred thousand dollars sure there
aren't that many hours in the year but
here's the thing she claims that the
majority of those hours come from work
that she does for the black community
for like black lives matter that doesn't
count no one is a ski that's not
affiliated with the school no one's
asking whatever you do at home has
nothing to do with that anyways the
school obviously said they wanted the
money back they try to sue her and they
started a whole campaign saying my
university is anti black and then they
started to put posters up they got
gathered a bunch of people saying that
you're their only suing her because
she's black you stole three hundred
thousand you took three hundred thousand
dollars girl like are you because you're
black are you kidding me does that not
even and when she you know they
vandalized the Student Union they have
like megaphone starts yelling saying
anti black racism happened to your hand
and it was just this whole ordeal like
it's oh gosh anyways what does it found
the best arguments to get people your
age to wake up to some of this stuff
like I know obviously they're watching
your videos yeah it's like probably your
your prime way of do
if you found simple arguments simple
phrases or whatever that you can use to
get some people out of this everything
can be explained the way through a
social economic standpoint you a lot of
the issues that the black community
faces because they're poor which is the
same issues that poor white community
space as well and you know there are
examples of black Americans and black
Canadians that do do well to do well and
you have to look at why they're doing
well okay so they have higher education
you know there's they're both parents or
at home there are all these different
factors to look at and it's like oh so
it's not just the color of my skin
it's either choices aren't I make or the
area I'm in the surroundings I'm in or
the school I went to rather than just
it's the color of my skin but I think
you just have to break it down to that
before a lot of people can understand
where I'm coming from and why I think a
certain way it's just it's easy to just
to say well it's because I'm black and
I'm not doing as well it's no there's
there's so many different ways to
explain it how do you rub off all the
the stuff that they must say about you
because I have enough friends that are
black conservatives or are kind of
liberal whenever you want to call it
that the things that I see get that get
said about them all everytime larry
elder comes and does my show and I look
on Twitter the things that the things
that's the supposed tolerant people
right the progressives the lefties that
they say about this man who I know is
being authentic well it's ridiculous I
mean I get a lot of hate comments where
it's you know they'll call me [ __ ] they
say I hate myself I want to be white all
these different things like it's the one
part is like me speaking this way of
speaking I guess I want to say proper
English per se but it I trying to be why
I'm trying to be something I'm not and
it's like why are you fitting people a
race in a group you're just allowing
white people just to say well black
people are just dumb because if you say
we all act the same way and we should
all think the same way that means you
can every black person can be explained
with one statement that's not fair let
us all be individuals in fact you should
be fighting for us to be individuals and
have our own ideas why are we trying to
form groups and then you know they
wonder why why there's all these like
white supremacist groups forming up
because you've already it's a sites
thing you said there's ours
and there's your slide so you're like
okay sure we'll form a group I guess and
go against you but yeah I mean I don't a
lot of the hate comments are just
useless I ignore the epithets but I do
try to understand a lot of the criticism
and again it's just not understanding
where I'm coming from it's not you know
getting their stats from the right place
the route calm or onion it's not
somewhere to get your facts I like that
you compare those but when I you know
get into a detailed discussion with a
lot of them then they understand where
I'm coming from and it's like there's
this light that kind of shines and I do
that in my school a lot as well where
someone that absolutely hates me I spend
a whole day talking to them and at the
end I call it like it's really awful to
use its conversion therapy
well you're not electrocuting you know
but by the end of it it's like their
minds are blown because they just
believed everything blacklivesmatter
said everything the main stream left
media have said so it's I think it's
just you just gotta talk to them they
don't want to talk they're stuck in echo
chamber yeah do you see this
intersectionality and this combining of
perceived oppressions something that
will just sort of crap out under its own
weight so like for example if you're
gonna keep saying well black people
should or this minority whatever that
minority is should get easier entrance
to this or access to this or whatever
what you're actually saying is well
other people are going to have to be
punished based on their immutable
characteristics we see this now I mean I
see a massive split happening with the
Asian community right now in America
because by every metric that we judge
success they are succeeding at extremely
high levels became hard work and
education and commitment to family but
if you're gonna start saying well we're
gonna have to take less of them because
we have to take more leatherby look
you're actually setting these groups to
hate each other yeah that is so
dangerous and you're telling one group
that they can't do it on their own and
there are some studies I forgot who was
what it was who wrote it but it was
called the mismatch theory which is a
lot of the student minority students are
getting thrown in universities or to not
qualified actually turn out worse when
they come out they don't get jobs
because they don't have the actual
skills that they needed to get in but
yeah it creates cutting this kind of
tension why would you tell someone that
you know they're more important just
because of the color of your skin it's
gonna piss other people off it's I don't
think that
a way to move forward I don't think
that's a way to progress but yeah and
the whole intersectionality thing it's
it's ridiculous the Pride Parade I guess
in Toronto is an example of that it's
like my issues are more important and
then obviously the LGBTQ community they
all hated that and they were all very
upset with it because it's like pride is
one of the most inclusive you know
events in the in the city why are you
trying to ruin it and say this is a
black thing it's an everybody thing
we're we're all advocating for everyone
here so it's it's they're just going to
yeah they're going to ruin themselves if
they keep just biting each other
speaking of that I saw the thing that
you did you were not happy when they put
the black and brown oh yeah stripes into
the rainbow flag which I also thought
was completely it's the whole point is
that this is for everybody we're not
looking at all your differences in all
your races yeah but what thing it's like
reverse segregation I really don't get
it the white privilege conference at
Ryerson University yeah that's reverse
segregation and I actually gave them the
benefit of the doubt I'm like I'm gonna
ignore the name I'm going to actually
try to see what they're trying to teach
and ultimately the end the conclusion of
this event was listen to people listen
to what people are saying so anecdotes
only listening folks are their feelings
so it's like that's not how you form a
society it's the majority we're white
women that were just sitting there
hearing black people tell them just
listen to our stories because we know
and we experience it and you know you we
have to have you know black spaces in
fact there is someone that tweeted
during the event saying a woman just
rolls our hand to speak while white
splaining wait for the for later where
we have our white corner so we can talk
about you know our what is this what
kind of society are we preparing
yourself for it's literally reverse
segregation or segregation in the true
sense of the word and yeah I really
don't what do you make of them guilty
white a lie
those people you know when I've had I
know you met Brett lines now yeah from
Evergreen and and Heather his wife one
of the things that fascinated me most
when he was going through the ordeal
there was that he said he never feared
the black students physically or the
brown students or whatever it was that
it was the white allies he said that had
this sort of look in their eye like they
were the ones that
could get violent and I've seen that
that look what do you make of that date
of ginned up hatred because it's hard to
do if you're not black then I mean there
try to explain it if you're not black
thing you don't experience it then you
don't understand it so as a white I lie
you have to just take everything you
know an activist says to you as fast as
this is what is happening one of the
speakers actually he did an interview
for the Toronto Star and they asked him
and that was like okay what where do you
see white privilege in Toronto and he
said leader like I mean I'm crazy but he
said when you walk into a store black
people of our black people have to think
about the fact that people are watching
them okay sure I was like fine whatever
but apparently black people have to pay
for items in one section before they can
move to another section so they don't
get accused of stealing that's his his
he got a chance to tell us what white
privilege is and that was his example of
white privilege does that happen again
no never it's never happened I've worked
retail for the most of my life what
you're gonna like pay the kids section
before you go to the men's section like
what world is this guy living in it blew
my mind and another one you know did an
article where it's how the outdoors is
racist and how you know people feel like
the you know skiing and hiking and
everything is a white space and
therefore black people don't want to go
to it and it's like who you're saying it
you are the one that are making both
claims why are we it's just more
division it's more like it pisses me off
yeah you know what we're gonna because
you're visiting a lifer yeah I don't
have a ton of time but maybe we could go
on a quick hike and see what happens but
it's just like you're obviously don't
care about the benefits of the black
community because you wouldn't be
talking about these non issues here in
the states you can talk about you know
sorry how the education system works you
can talk about the war on drugs you can
talk about the prison system but yeah
the amount of people they got to protest
the trayvon martin you know the shooting
if you can get that many people to
protest the war on drugs you can
probably make a change but no they're
gonna focus on you know i think police
shootings is one of the least things
that are actually affecting black
americans but yet that's what they want
to put their focus on so how much you're
the root of that is just lazy thinking
like
it's easy to get people ginned up about
a shooting per se mm-hmm and I'm not I'm
not diminishing ya wires that are wrong
for sure obviously it's but it's clear
it's easier to take all of the antic
Dotel's stuff the woman at the shopping
center who this happened to or that yeah
it's always easier to do that than to
really be like let's really look at the
prison systems which I would be for
looking yeah I would be figuring out
ways that we can make do better
education to minority communities that
have been neglected all of those things
but those things aren't really sexy
they're not like the things that get
people out on the streets yeah for more
than a day it's the other stuff so part
of this is just human nature right yeah
I totally agree I mean I I can base all
my arguments on anecdotes but that
doesn't like that means nothing to me I
can just say oh well this one day I've
lived in Toronto all my life and I've
never experienced racism I'm not gonna
use that as facts but yeah but it's so
much easier to do so it's so much easier
to you know play with the heartstrings
and say that this is what's really
happening but it's just it's just sad
that there are actual policies that you
know can be changed or put in place that
could actually uplift the black
community but you know none of the
people that are that claim to be the
activists care and especially the
celebrities which really annoys me
Beyonce and jay-z all they do is talk
about you know black rice and blue why
why don't you use your billion dollars
to you know create some rehabilitation
center for people that are getting out
of prison why don't you try to fight for
the war on drugs like it's all these
things where it's it's yeah it's it's
easy just to say oh look there's a
shooting you know this is what black
people experience every day and you know
white people are racist the end no it's
theirs it's easier for them to just to
say look at this anecdote in this
shooting and that's what's affecting us
there's so many other things that could
be done yeah I think you saw a little
bit of my appearance at University of
New Hampshire when those kids were oh
yeah yelling at me and when that one
woman who I don't think was a student I
think she was either a mother of a
student nurse or an adviser saying when
she kept saying you know these kids
pointing to the black kids could get
shot when they walked out of here she's
talking about at University of New
Hampshire and it's like actually that
was one of the only moments where I
didn't know what to say because it was
so crazy to say that like you're not
gonna be shot and you walk out of here
yeah and I think I maybe said something
to that effect but like it's like that's
really dangerous
a line of thinking I totally agree and I
was actually having a I went to a comedy
club the other day and there's this guy
on stage he was like typical inner-city
black youth or whatever and he after his
that he came to sit in my table everyone
was gone and he made a comment saying
wow it was really hard to be a black
woman in in this country and this is
again this is Canada I feel like there's
no excuses for Canada like get out of
here
okay I asked him okay how and he's just
like I don't know it's just it's really
hard to be you know a woman and black
I'm like yeah I get the whole woman
thing because you know men are you know
physically bigger and bull ah but why is
it hard for me to be black in Toronto
specifically and he's like you know cuz
you know there's just white privilege
I'm like no no give me two reasons
concrete reasons could not come up with
one because there isn't you can't come
up with one you have to use the
anecdotes you have to use the you know
if you walk out in the street you're
gonna get shot why what are the
statistics of people that get shot by
police oh seven gets shot by police per
year and it's not recorded by race and
it's also doesn't tell us if they're
armed or on our seven people and you're
telling me you're more likely to walk
out the door as a black person gets shot
that's not an epidemic
you know what's an epidemic the crime in
black communities that's an epidemic but
you want to ignore that and just talk
about the other yeah anecdotes that pull
at the heartstrings and make people feel
guilty and it's it's a waste of time
it's such a waste of time what are your
parents think about what you're doing
well they're conservatives so they love
it so what it's not conservative with
some if someone was to say you're you're
conservative I watch your videos yeah
talk about conservatism is not that bad
blah blah blah what why would you not
say you're conservative putting aside
the the exhaustion of labels first yeah
oh I was saying fiscally conservative so
I guess I do believe in like lower taxes
in some sense I do believe in the free
market I do believe in you know less
regulations all that fun stuff but at
the same time I do think that there
should be some sort of social safety net
and you know living in Canada where
there is you know sorry free health not
free health care universal health care
and you know at universal education the
education system is amazing the the
funding for your education system is
amazing so stuff like that where I think
I'm a little bit more liberal where I do
think the government should help
in some way but it's cuz I'm used to it
it's what I grew up with and I haven't
really seen anything different and it
works works fine so I guess that and I'm
pro-choice so stuff like that where I
really do stand firm in my liberal views
and ideas and then yeah I'm fiscally
conservative yeah well we're pretty much
alive finally found now we can go out
hiking yeah we just start beating people
in fact I don't know what place to do
once you find it out like that's how it
works
something like that where do you want to
go with all this I've seen it I've seen
your channel grow I think obviously you
know having you here it'll it'll boost
your profile a little bit you can go
into politics what are you gonna do
Prime Minister can take out that Trudeau
guy with his fancy socks what he should
go oh gosh well maybe maybe Peterson
will do it but you can't I lead in this
cabinet yeah definitely sorry well I am
enjoying what I'm doing now and I'm
quite surprised that people even enjoy
watching my videos
I think it's cool to do something you
love and people like it as well like I
really am having fun doing it and I
think I would probably go into politics
later in life I mean I am doing
political science it has to be useful
somewhere I've been toying around with
law but again I'm not sure if I really
want to be in you know the whole I don't
know if I want to deal with law school
but and I'm starting actually a podcast
with my boyfriend which I would be
uploaded very soon nice yeah by the way
we should tell people yes they'll find
out otherwise your boyfriend is white
yes which means you could have
potentially children who look black yeah
they might look white and they look a
little bit of both you've talked about
that a little bit it doesn't really
matter to you no no
yeah my boyfriend being white has been
used as like an attack against me saying
like wow look at you
what does they say sleeping with the
devil or something like that and it's
just seems like a decent fella that's a
great guy he played in ten do it no he's
a great guy but again it's it's the
whole idea of why are you creating more
divisive this and then saying you want
equality why are you saying a black
woman being with the white man is bad
and then say wow white people are mean
to me like can you either
equality or you don't you either want
individuality or you don't pick one you
can't have both again and it's sorry
well yeah yeah I'm not a hundred percent
sure where exactly I will be in the next
five years I'm having fun with what I'm
doing now I work for the National Post
which I absolutely love and then I have
the podcast coming so that's what I'm
gonna do for now and maybe I might get
into politics but ah it's so messy the
fact that you even are going that far
right now you're doing it oh god yeah I
hate to tell you I can see it now how
exciting I'll have somebody to support
and care you know what you get you do
something in Canada where you run and
you become something mayor or something
whatever you want to do I will consider
moving oh my big freaking test see what
happens definitely do you think I do
okay there are y-k oh no I'm sorry
you're done you're done for you're gonna
have to start giving me like half of
your pages cuz you know racism and stuff
yeah okay but I think one thing that I
would actually probably like to do which
I probably will not be able to but to do
a lot of work in like inner-city
communities because I I want to say I've
lived through it but I understand what's
going on there I understand that you
know there's a high-crime understand
that in some neighborhoods the schools
aren't that's good for Canada it's a
little different but I'd like to do some
work there where I can kind of tell them
hey I got out and here's what I did to
get out and you can do it too there's so
many there's opportunities there for you
like if you were poor minorities you
know child right now please just try
your hardest at school you get an
education it's literally one of the
greatest opportunities that you can have
and you're more likely I mean you're
probably not a hundred percent great but
you're more likely to be successful if
you get an education and that's the one
thing a lot of black you know people are
lacking is the education component and
you know we don't really have like the
war on drugs and everything so it really
is weird for me that in inner cities of
Toronto where there's still this very
high crime there's still this tension
but you know have you ever heard of the
Woodson Center by any chance it's a
nonprofit organization it's located in
DC but I've been working with them for
some time and they basically do the same
thing they
go out to these neighborhoods and they
help students and they have such a good
success rate they help them in high
school because that's the other thing is
that a lot of black kids are not even
graduating high school of course they're
gonna go into crime if you're not even
graduating high school so yeah they work
with a lot of students they're they you
know have rehabilitation centers they
help you know black sorry black
Americans reintegrate into society like
it's stuff like that words these
grassroot movements and I would really
like to do and I know it's a it's a big
dream but I think that's where he'll
probably be happiest is where I can show
people how it's done and help them and
hopefully everyone can copy that and say
oh this is what we're supposed to do and
all that but awesome I love it and I
have no doubt that you're gonna do it
and you guys can follow this future
member of Canadian Parliament on her
YouTube channel right here in
youtube.com / my name is Josephine
[Music]
you